[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
historia en tiempos en los que el mundo
asiste a una vacunación global cabe
recordar que hace 80 años se llevó a
cabo por primera vez en la historia un
tratamiento de penicilina en un ser
humano un policía británico de 43 años
albert alexander fue el primer paciente
de penicilina su médico en el hospital
radcliffe en oxford inglaterra tras
verlo en un estado moribundo le ofreció
el tratamiento experimental se trataba
de agotar el último recurso ya que
alexander había sido desahuciado luego
de que la infección que comenzó en la
cara afectara sus vías respiratorias de
manera que el 12 de febrero de 1941 el
doctor charts fletcher lo trató con
penicilina y marcó un hito en la
historia y es que previamente a la
década de 1940 un ser humano era
propenso a morir por una simple cortada
que después se infectara por el
crecimiento de bacterias de hecho la
historia en cuestión del policía es que
se cortó con una rosa
lo verídico es que una herida maltratada
desde tiempos inmemoriales podría
suponer la muerte por siglos y
desconociendo su toxicidad la forma de
combatir las bacterias en el cuerpo
humano era con inyecciones de mercurio
ya para finales del siglo 19 y comienzos
del siglo 20 los avances en el estudio
de los microorganismos permitieron que
un médico alemán paul ehrlich allá del
compuesto 606 o salvar sanz proveniente
del arsénico de allí que años más tarde
los antibióticos revolucionarán el mundo
como agentes biológicos que eliminan
selectivamente a los gérmenes y que por
ende salvan millones de vidas cuenta la
historia que un médico de origen escocés
al regresar después de un mes de
vacaciones a trabajar en su laboratorio
en el hospital saint mary de londres
encontró algo inusual un hongo en uno de
sus cultivos de bacterias de sus placas
de petri estamos hablando del célebre
médico alexander fleming quien no todo
ese comportamiento extraño en uno de sus
cultivos de bacterias el 28 de
septiembre de 1928 de manera que ayudado
por un colega y por el uso del micro
determinaron que había un halo de
transparencia alrededor de ese modo una
muerte celular de las bacterias la
serendipia de flaming o el valioso
hallazgo por casualidad le valió 17 años
después el premio nobel de medicina un
galardón que compartió con howard flor y
profesor de patología en la escuela sir
william donde la universidad de oxford y
ernst von itzstein bioquímico alemán
ambos retomaron la investigación sobre
la penicilina que alexander fleming
había desestimado en 1934 luego de
encontrar serios obstáculos tanto en la
purificación como en la síntesis para el
antibiótico fue howard flor y el
profesor de oxford junto a otros dos el
químico alemán eres change y el biólogo
británico norman heatley los encargados
de purificar la penicilina en 1939 justo
ese año
europa entró en la segunda guerra
mundial el conflicto bélico que con más
de 50 millones de muertos es el más
mortífero en la historia de la humanidad
la campaña devastadora
de la alemania nazi puso a europa en
jaque ya millones de soldados en campos
de batalla sufriendo agonizantes
enfermedades por infecciones disparos de
bala esquirlas bombardeos producían gran
cantidad de heridos que quedaban a su
suerte si la herida no progresaba ante
semejante panorama en mayo de 1940 el
grupo de oxford en inglaterra determinó
profundizar la producción de la
penicilina los primeros experimentos se
realizaron con ratones de laboratorio a
ocho los inocularon con el estreptococo
una bacteria mortal a cuatro de ellos
les dieron penicilina dando como
resultado que sobrevivieron mientras que
los otros cuatro murieron prontamente el
resultado positivo alentó a los
científicos a experimentar con humanos
pero la penicilina purificada era un
tratamiento dispendioso una cosa era
administrarla en ratones y otra en
humanos
pese a los dificultoso de la empresa ya
pusieron en marcha en la escuela de
patología de oxford disponiendo tinas
bidones jarrones
y demás espacios cóncavos dónde
purificar la penicilina así llegó el 12
de febrero de 1941 hace 80 años cuando
al policía albert alexander le
inyectaron por primera vez penicilina la
herida de albert alexander en la cara se
traspasó a las vías respiratorias ante
la premura de un tratamiento acepto la
penicilina con tan buen resultado que al
día siguiente presentó mejoras pero la
penicilina purificada durante todo un
año apenas alcanzó para cinco días de
tratamiento pese a la muerte en marzo de
albert alexander pero convencidos del
logro el grupo de oxford buscó producir
penicilina a gran escala tocando puertas
en la industria química del reino unido
no obstante la guerra primaba en la
industria no se arriesgó por la
penicilina al grupo de oxford no le
quedó otra alternativa que emigrar hacia
eeuu
para entonces los norteamericanos no
habían entrado en guerra y su economía y
desarrollo científico se demostraban
pujantes así que el grupo de oxford
arribo específicamente a los
laboratorios de peoria en illinois
allí el biólogo británico norman heatley
y el microbiólogo estadounidense andrew
mogel lograron multiplicar por una
decena la cantidad de antibiótico que
obtenían del proceso de fermentación de
la penicilina esto llevó a la producción
en masa del antibiótico que para 1943 ya
se vendía en forma de ampolla y fue de
inmensa ayuda para los soldados aliados
durante la segunda guerra mundial hasta
que llegamos hoy andrés suárez jaramillo
gracias por compartir estas historias
que las encuentran en los programas de
france 24 punto com
[Música]